sévit aux biens avait autorisé on vient
on va aller en prison ils ont défié
l'état pendant quatre ans de 1977 à 1981
une radio est née clandestinement à
paris radio verte une station pirate
illégal proposé au monopole d'état sur
la radiodiffusion est lancée par une
bande d'amis parmi eux l'essayiste
antoine lefébure
aux quatre coins de la capitale l'équipe
est hébergée par des amis les auditeurs
il faut diffuser sur tout paris alors
l'émetteur et placer le plus haut
possible comme sur ces images à
montmartre
recherché
paris mais ces radios pirates ne
plaisent pas à tout le monde certains
sourcils ecoutez jean christophe averty
figure de l'audiovisuel et pilier de
radio france c'était en 1977 c'est pas
la peine d'avoir une réunion de quartier
ça ne signifie rien c'est complètement
imbécile sellal aberration démocratique
ce
sens par tout le monde va parler en main
heureuse en parler c'est un art
inconsciemment menacé par quelque chose
qui pouvait leur rendre de la place sur
la fréquence de l'audience etc
et puis je pense qu'il était sincère les
jantes et ce à travers moi j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration pour lui et sincèrement il
ne comprenait pas mais personne ne
comprenait personnes passent dans l'est
dans les grands médias personne ne
comprenait la l'intérêt de l'opération
et personne ne voulait nous aider et le
premier opposant à radio verte c'est
l'état qui a la mainmise sur la radio et
la télévision française la station est
régulièrement brouillées censuré par la
police et parfois les menaces pouvait
aller beaucoup plus loin moi quand je
rentrais chez moi
les plafonniers à lui mais c'est vrai
que j'étais pas très fier mais je
le 9 novembre 1981 cette censure se
termine le président françois mitterrand
élu quelques mois plus tôt met fin au
monopole d'état sur la radiodiffusion
les stations pirates ne sont plus
illégales elles deviennent des radios
libres et c'était une révolution à
l'époque nous on était très contents
qu'elle si cette liberté d'expression
qui apparaît une radio en basque une
radio anarchiste une radio catholique de
tera ça nous ça nous a paru dès le début
quelque chose de formidable c'est radio
verte disparaît en mai 1981 quelques
mois avant la libération des ondes
aujourd'hui le csa comptabilise 1021 une
radio privée en france
[Musique]